and I just decided to tweet some basic
things that my mother told me growing up
um and you know this is wisdom that we
conventionally got from our grandmothers
our great grandmothers um our fathers
but for some reason in modern society
everything has just been lost I really
don't get it um so I tweeted men don't
generally like fat chicks so I've been
getting a lot of heat for not bringing
up the exception to the rule so I was
like you know what I am today I'm
feeling so kind I'll even add it
generally I won't put men don't like fat
chicks I'll put men generally don't like
fat chicks or men don't generally like
fat chicks and you know I know there's
exceptions there's the chubby chasers
but that doesn't make it the rule and um
what what do we get do we get women
saying I agree with you this is such a
great point